to our best understanding today how
deadly is covered
do we have a good measure
for for this very question
so the the best evidence for covet the
deadliness of covet comes from a whole
series of Sierra prevalent studies
Sierra prevalent studies are these
studies of antibody prevalence in the
population at Large
I was part of the you know the very
first set of cereal problem studies one
in Santa Clara County one in L.A county
and one in other with Major League
Baseball around the U.S uh if I may just
pause you for a second
if people don't know what uh serology is
and Sarah prevalence it does sound like
you say zero prevalence it's not it's
zero and serology's antibodies so it's
it's a it's a survey that counts the
number of antibodies specifically people
that have antibodies
specific to covid which perhaps shows an
indication that they likely have had
covet and therefore this is a way to
study how many people in the population
have been exposed to have had exactly
yeah exactly so the idea is that uh
we don't know exactly the number of
people with covet just by counting the
people that are that present themselves
with symptoms of covet um covet has it
turns out a very wide range of symptoms
possible ranging from no symptoms at all
to this deadly viral pneumonia that's
killed so many people and the problem is
like in if you just count the number of
cases the people who have very few
symptoms often don't show up for testing
we just don't they're outside of the can
of Public Health
and so it's really hard to know the the
answer to your question without
understanding how many people are
infected because you you can probably
tell the number of deaths that's even
though there's some controversy over
that but uh that so the the numerator is
possible but the denominator is much
harder how much controversy is there
about the death we're going to go on
million tangents is that okay we're
gonna I have a million questions so one
I love data so much but I'm like almost
tuned out paying attention to covid data
because I feel like I'm walking on Shaky
Ground I don't know who to trust
um maybe you can comment on different
sources of data different kinds of data
the death one that seems like a really
important one can we trust the reported
deaths associated with covid or is it
just a giant messy thing that mixed up
and then there's this kind of stories
about hospitals being incentivized uh to
report a death as covet death so uh
there's some truth in some of that let
me just so let me just talk about the
incentive so in the United States
we passed this cares act that was aimed
at making sure Hospital assistants
didn't go bankrupt in the early days of
the pandemic the couple things they did
one was they provided incentives to
treat coveted patients tens of thousands
of dollars extra per per coveted patient
and the other thing they did is they
they gave a 20 bump to Medicare payments
for elderly patients who treated with
covet the idea is that there's more
expensive to treat them at I guess the
early days
um so that did provide an incentive to
sort of have have a lot of coveted
patients in the hospital because your
financial uh success of the hospital or
at least not the lack of financial ruin
depended on having many coveted patients
the other thing on the death
certificates is the reporting of death
is a separate issue I don't know that
there's a financial incentive there but
there is this sort of like complicated
you know when you fill out a death
certificate
for a patient with a lot of conditions
like let's say a patient has diabetes a
patient that while that diabetes could
lead to to uh heart failure you have a
heart attack heart failure your lungs
fill up then you get covid and what and
you die so what do you what do you write
on the death certificate was it was it
covered that killed you was it the lungs
filling up was it the the heart failure
was it the diabetes it's really
difficult to like disentangle
um and I think a lot of a lot of times
what's happened is they people have like
aired on the side of signing as covet
now what's the evidence of this there's
been a couple of of audits of death
certificates in places like Santa Clara
County where I live in Alameda County uh
California where they they carefully
went through the justifica said okay is
this reasonable to say this was actually
coveted or is it was coveted incidental
and they found that about 25 20 25 of
the deaths were more likely incidental
than directly due to covid I I
personally don't get too excited about
this I mean it's a philosophical
question right like ultimately what
kills you which is an odd thing to say
if you if you're if you're not you're
not in medicine but like really it's
it's a
um it's almost always multifactorial
it's always not always just the bus hits
you the bus hits you that you get a
brain bleed was the brain bleed that
killed you would it burst anyway I mean
you know the bus hit you killed you
right the way you die is a philosophical
question but it's also a sociological
and psychological question because it
seems like
every single person who was passed away
over the past couple years kind of the
first question that comes to mind
not not just because you're trying to be
political but just in your mind no I
think there's a psychological reason for
this right so um
you know we have we spent uh the better
part of a at least a half century in the
United States not worried too much about
infectious diseases and we the notion
was we'd essentially conquered them it
was something that happens in Far Away
places uh to other people
and and that's true for much of the
developed world life expectancy were
going up for you know decades and
decades and for the first time in living
memory we have a disease that can kill
us I mean I think we're effectively
evolved to fear that like the the Panic
centers of our brain the lizard part of
our brain takes over
and our Central Focus has been avoiding
this one risk
um and so it's not surprising that that
people when they're filling out death
certificates or thinking about what what
led to the death this most Salient thing
that's in the front of everyone's brain
would jump to the top
and we can't ignore this very deep
psychological thing when we consider
what people say on the internet what
people say to each other what people
write in scientific papers but
everything it feels like
when covid has been
um
has been brought onto this world
everything changed in the way people
feel about each other just the way they
communicate with each other I think the
the level of emotion involved
I think it in many people it brought out
the worst in them
for sometimes short periods of time and
sometimes there's always therapeutic
like you were waiting to get out like
the darkest parts of you just to say if
you're angry at something in this world
I'm going to say it now and um I think
that's probably talking to some deep
primal thing that
um fear we have for um
formalities of all different kinds and
then when that fear is aroused and all
the deepest emotions it's like a
Freudian
Psychotherapy session but across the
world something that psychologists are
going to have a field day with for
Generation trying to understand
um I mean I think I think what you say
is right but piled on top of that is
also this sort of
uh this impetus to empathy they're
empathize compassion toward others
essentially militarized right so I'm
protecting you
by by some actions and uh those actions
if I if I don't do them if you don't do
them well that must mean you don't just
you you hate me
um it's created this like social tension
that I've never seen before and we and
we and we start have started we started
we looked at each other as if we were
just simply sources of of germs rather
than people to get to know people to
enjoy people to get you know to learn
from
um it it coloreds basically almost every
human interaction for every every human
on the planet yeah the basic common
Humanity it's like you can wear a mask
you can stand far away but the love you
have for each other when you look into
each other's eyes that was dissipating
and and by region too I've experienced
having traveled quite a bit throughout
this time
it um it was really sad even people that
are really close together just the way
they stood the way they looked at each
other and I it made me feel for a moment
um that the fabric that connects all of
us is more fragile than I thought I mean
if you walk down the street or if you
ever if you did this during covet I'm
sure you had this experience where you
walk down the street if you're not
wearing a mask or even if you are people
will jump off the off the sidewalk that
you walk past them as if you're poisoned
even though the data are that covet
spreads you know indifferently Outdoors
if at all really Outdoors but it's not
simply a biological or infectious
disease phenomena epidemiological it is
a it is a it's a it is a change in the
way humans treated each other I hope
hope temporary I I do want to say on the
flip side of that so I was mostly in
Boston Massachusetts when the pandemic
broke out I think that's where I was
yeah
and then I got came here to Austin Texas
to visit my now good friend Joe Rogan
and he was the first person without
pause this wasn't a political statement
this was anything just walk toward me
give me a big hug and say it's great to
see you and I can't tell you how great
it felt because I in that moment
realized the absence of that connection
back in Boston over just a couple of
over a couple of months and um
it's we'll talk about it more but it's
tragic to think about that distancing
that dissolution of common Humanity at
scale what what kind of impact it has on
society just across the board political
division uh and just in the quiet of
your own mind in the privacy of your own
home the depression the sadness the
loneliness that leads to suicide
and forget suicide just
low-key suffering yeah no I think that's
that's the suffering that isolation
we're not meant to live alone we're not
meant to live apart from one another but
that's of course the ideology of
lockdown is to make people live apart
alone isolated so that we don't spread
diseases to each other right but we're
not actually designed as a species to
live that way
and that uh what you're describing I
think if everyone's honest with
themselves have felt especially in
places where where that where lockdowns
have been sort of very militantly
enforced has felt deep into their core
well I if I could just return to the
question of deaths
he said that the data isn't perfect
because we need these kind of uh serial
prevalence surveys to understand how
many cases there were to determine the
rate of death and we need to have a
strong footing in the number of deaths
but if we assume that the the number of
deaths is approximately correct like
what's your sense what kind of
statements can we say about the
deadliness of covet against across
different demographics maybe not in a
political way or in the current way but
when history looks back at this moment
of time 50 years from now 100 years from
now the way we look at the pandemic 100
years ago
what will they say about the deadliness
of code I mean I think the deadlines of
covet depends on not just the virus
itself but who who it infects
um so the probably the most important
thing about it about the deadlines of
covet is is this steep age gradient in
the mortality rate
um so according to these zero prevalent
studies that that have been done now
hundreds of them
um mostly from before vaccination this
vaccination also reduces the mortality
risk of covid the the cereal problem
studies suggests that uh the risk of of
death if you say over the age of 70 is
very high if you know five percent
if you get covered
if you're if you're under the age of 70
it's lower 0.05 but there's not a single
sharp cut off it's more like I have a
rule of thumb that I use so if you're 50
say the infection fatality rate from
covet is 0.2 percent according to the
zero prevalence data that means 99.8
survival
if you're 50. and for every seven years
of age above that double it every seven
years of age below that habit
so a 57 year old have a point four
percent uh mortality a 64 year old would
have a point eight percent and so on and
if you have a severe chronic disease
like diabetes or if you're more morbidly
obese it's like adding seven seven years
to your life
and this is uh for unvaccinated folks
this is unvaccinated uh in the before
Delta also are there a lot of people
that will be listening to this with phds
at the end of their name that would
disagree with the 99.8 would you say so
I think there's some disagreement over
this uh and the disagreement is about
the quality of the serial prevalence
studies that that were conducted uh so
as I said earlier I was a senior
investigator in three different stereo
problem studies very early in the
epidemic
um I view them as very high quality
studies
um we we um in Santa Clara County what
we did is we used a a test kit uh to
that we obtained from uh someone who was
Works in Major League Baseball actually
he had ordered these test kits very
early in March 2020 that measures very
accurately measures antibody levels or
antibodies in the in in the bloodstream
uh this test kits were eventually were
approved by the the uh had a eua by the
emergency use authorization by the FDA
sort of shortly after we did this and uh
it had a very low false positive rate
false positive means if you if you uh if
you don't have these coveted antibodies
in your in your bloodstream the kit
shows up positive anyways that that
turns out to happen about point five
percent of the time
um and uh based on studies a very large
number of studies looking at blood from
2018 you try it against this kit
and uh you know 0.5 of the 2018 there
shouldn't be antibodies there so for
Jacob it's if it sounds positive it's a
false positive it's point five percent
of the time
um and then you know like a false
negative rate uh about uh 10 12
something like that I don't remember the
exact number but the false positive rate
is the important thing there right so
you have a population in March 2020 or
April 2020 with very low fraction of
patients having been exposed to code you
don't know how much but low
even a small false positive rate could
end up
biasing your study quite a bit but
there's a formula to adjust for that you
can adjust for the for false positive
rate Falls negative rate we did we did
that adjustment and those studies found
in a community population so leaving
aside people in nursing homes who have a
higher death rate from covid
um the that the death rate was 0.2
percent in Santa Clara County and in LA
county across all age groups in the
community community meeting just like
regularly yeah so like that that's a
real important question too so uh the
Santa Clara study we did this Facebook
sampling scheme
um which is I mean not not the ideal
thing but it's like it was very
difficult to get a random sample and
during the you know during lockdown
um where we put out a an ad on Facebook
soliciting people to volunteer for the
study uh randomly selected set of people
we were hoping to get a random selection
people from Santa Clara County but it
tended to the people who tend to
volunteer were from the Richer parts of
the county like I had Stanford
professors writing begging to be in the
study because they wanted another
antibody levels so we did some
adjustment for that in LA county we
hired a firm that had a pre-existing
representative sample of LA County
um uh so but it didn't include nursing
homes it didn't include people in jail
things like that didn't include the
homeless populations so it's it's
representative of a community dwelling
population
both of those and there we found that
both in L.A county and Santa Clara
County in April 2020 something like 40
to 50 times more infections than cases
in both places
so for every case that had been reported
to the public health authorities we
found that you know you know 40 or 50
other infections people with antibodies
in their blood that suggested that
they'd had coveted and recovered so
people were not reporting or severe at
least in those days Under reporting yeah
I mean there was for you know there's
testing problem I mean there weren't so
many tests available people didn't know
a lot of a lot of them we asked a set of
questions about the symptoms that faced
and mosten said they face no symptoms or
at the most uh 30 40 of them said face
their no symptoms
and I mean even these days how many
people report that they get covered when
they get covered okay I'll have those
numbers that point two percent has that
approximately held up over time that is
so if Professor Johnny and Edis who's a
colleague of mine at Stanford uh is a
world expert in Madden now it's probably
the most excited scientist on Earth I
think at least living he he did a
meta-analysis of now a hundred or more
of these Sarah prevalent studies
um and uh what he found was that that
0.2 percent is roughly the worldwide
number I mean in fact I think you
besides this lower number 0.15 percent
as the median infection fatality rate
worldwide so we did these studies and it
generated an enormous amount of blowback
by people who thought that the infection
of dehydrate is much higher
and there's some controversy over the
quality of some of the other studies
that that are done and so there are some
people who look at this same literature
and say well the the lower quality
studies tend to have lower IFRS the
higher quality studies as far oh
infection fatality right I apologize I
do this in lectures too and I'm going to
rudely interrupt your uh and ask for uh
for the basics sometimes if it's okay no
of course so these these higher quality
studies they say are pretend to produce
higher but the problem is that if you
want a global eye infection fatality
rate you need to get serial prevalent
studies from everywhere even places that
don't necessarily have the
infrastructure set up to produce very
very high quality studies
and in poor places in the world
the the like places like Africa the
infection fatality rate is incredibly
low
and in some richer places
like New York City the infection
fatalities is is much higher
uh it's there's a range of IFRS in a
single number
this sometimes surprises people uh
because they think well it's a it's a
virus it should have the same properties
no matter where it goes but the the
virus
kills or infects or hurts in interaction
with the host
and the properties of both the host and
the virus combine to produce the the
outcome but you also mentioned the
environment too uh well it's I'm
thinking mainly just about the person
like if I'm going to think about it like
the most simplest way to think about it
is age age is the single most important
risk factor so older places are going to
have a higher IFR
than younger places Africa three percent
of Africa is over 65. so in some sense
it's not surprising that they have a low
infection fatality rate so that's one
way you would explain the difference
between Africa and New York City in
terms of the fatality rate is the age
the average age yeah and then especially
in the early days of the epidemic in New
York City the uh older populations
living in nursing homes were
differentially infected
based on because of policies that were
adopted right to send coveted infected
patients back to nursing homes to keep
hospitals empty what do you mean by
differentially infected the policy that
you adopt determines who is most exposed
right that okay so that's what is the
policy it's the person that matters I
mean it's not like the virus just kind
of it doesn't care I mean the the policy
determines the nature of the interaction
and there's also I mean there is some
contribution from the environment
different regions have different
proximity maybe of people interacting or
the Dynamics of the way they interact
I'm like if you have a if you have
situations where there's lots of
intergenerational
uh interactions yeah then you have a
very different risk profile than if then
if you have societies that are where
Generations are more separate from one
another
um okay so let me just finish real fast
about this so you you have in New York
you have a population that was infected
in the early days that was very likely
going to die I had a high much higher
likelihood of dying if infected
and so New York City had a higher IFR
especially in the early days then um
then um then like Africa has had
um the other thing is treatment right so
the treatments that we adopted in the
early years the epidemic I think
actually may have exacerbated the risk
of death
[Music]
using ventilators like if the the over
Reliance on ventilators is what I'm
primarily thinking of but I can think of
other things
um but that that uh also we've learned
over time how better to manage patients
with the disease so you have those you
have all those things combined so that's
that's where the controversy over this
over this number is I mean New York City
also it is a is a central hub for those
who tweet
and uh those who write powerful stories
and narratives in article form and I
remember those quite dramatic stories
about sort of doctors in the hospitals
and these kinds of things I mean there's
very serious very dramatic very tragic
deaths going on always in hospitals
those stories
um a lot loved ones losing each other on
a death bed that's always tragic and you
can always write a hell of a good story
about that and you should about the loss
of loved ones but they were doing it
pretty pretty well I would say
um over this kind of dramatic deaths and
so in response to that it's very
unpleasant to hear even to consider the
possibility that the death rate is not
as high as you might otherwise as you
might feel yeah I was surprised by the
reaction
both by Regular People and also the
scientific community in response to
those studies those early studies in
April of 2020. um uh to me they uh they
were they were studies I mean they're
they're the kinds of not exactly the
kinds of work I've worked on all my life
but it's kind of kind of like the kind
of you know that you you write a paper
and you get response responses from your
fellow scientists and you you know
change the paper to improve it uh you
have you hopefully learned something
from it well but to pushback it's just a
study
but there's some studies and this is
kind of interesting because I've
received similar pushback on other
topics
there's some studies that if wrong might
have a wide ranging detrimental effects
on society so that's that that's the way
they would perceive the studies if you
say the death rate is lower and you end
up as you often do in science realizing
that nope that this that was there was a
flaw in the way they said it was
conducted or we just not representative
of a broader population and then you
realize that death rate is much higher
that might be very damaging in in
people's view uh so so that's probably
where the scientific Community sort of
just Steel Man the kind of response is
that's where they felt like you know
there's some findings where you better
be damn sure before you kind of report
them yeah I mean we were pretty sure we
were right and it turns out we were
right so like when we so um we released
the the Santa Clara study via this open
open science process and This Server
called Med archive it's it's designed
for releasing Studies have not yet been
pre-reviewed in order to Garner comment
from the from the scientists before peer
review
the the LA County study we went through
the traditional peer review process uh
and got it published in the Journal of
American Medical Association sometime in
like uh July I think I forget the date
of 2020. the Santa Clara study released
in April of 2020 in this you know sort
of working paper archive the the reason
was that we felt we had an obligation we
had a result that was we thought was
quite important and we wanted to tell
the scientific Community about it and
also tell the world about it and it
wasn't we wanted to get feedback I mean
that's part of the purpose of sending it
to these kinds of places I think a lot
of the problem is that uh when people
think about published science they think
of it as automatically true and if it
goes through peer reviews automatically
true if it hasn't gone through peer
review it's not automatically true and
especially in medicine when we're not
used to having this at this access to
pre-peer-reviewed
work I mean in economics actually that's
quite normal you it takes years to get
something published so there's a very
active debate over or discussion about
papers before they're peer-reviewed in
this in this sort of working paper way
um much less normal or much much newer
in in medicine
and so I think part of that the
perception about what those that that
What process happens in open science
when you release a study that that got
people confused and you're right it was
a very important result because we had
just locked the world down in middle of
March
with I think catastrophic results
and if the if that study was right if
our study was right that meant we'd made
a mistake
and not because the death rate was low
that's actually not the key thing there
the key thing is that we had adopted
these policies these tests and Trace
policies these policies these lockdown
policies aimed at suppressing the virus
level to close to zero that was
essentially the idea if we can just get
the virus to go away we won't have to
ever worry about it again
the main problem with our result as far
as that strategy was concerned wasn't
the death rate it was the 40 to 50 times
more infections than cases it was the
two and a half percent or uh three
percent or four percent prevalence rate
that we identified of the antibodies in
the population if that number is right
it's too late the virus is not going to
go to zero and no matter how much we
test and Trace and isolate we're not
going to get the viral level down to
zero
so we're going to have to let the virus
go through the entire population in some
way or so that we can talk about that in
a bit that's the Great Barrington
declaration you don't have to let the
virus go through the population you can
Shield preferentially
uh the the policy we chose was to Shield
preferentially the the laptop class the
set of people who could work from home
without losing their job
yeah and we did a very good job of
protecting them well let me um
take a small tangent we're going to jump
around in time
which I think will be the best way to
tell the story so that was the beginning
yeah okay actually can I go back one
more thing for that because that's
really important and I should have I
should have started with this
um what led me to do those studies was a
paper that I'd remembered seeing from
the H1N1 flu epidemic in 2009 this is
this is where I had been much less
active in writing about that I've
written up like a paper or two about
that when I in in 2009
um there there was actually the same
debate over the mortality rate except it
unfolded over the course of three years
two or three years
the early studies of the mortality rate
in H1N1 counted the number of cases
in the denominator kind of the number of
deaths in the numerator cases meaning
people identified as having H1N1 showing
up the doctor you know tested to have it
um and the earliest estimates of the
H1N1 mortality were like four percent
three percent really really high
over the course of a couple of more
years a whole bunch of zero prevalence
studies zero prevalent studies of H1N1
flu came out and it turned out that
there were a hundred or more times
people infected per case
and so the mortality rate was actually
something like 0.02 percent
for H1N1 not the three three like a
hundred-fold difference so this made you
think okay it took us a couple of two to
three years to discover the truth behind
the actual infections
uh for a H1N1 and then what's the truth
here and can we get there faster yeah
and and there was it spreads in the
similar way as the as the H1N1 fluid I
mean it spreads via solidation VIA you
know so person to person breathing kind
of kind of contact up um and maybe maybe
some by film eyes but it seems like
that's less likely now in any case it
seemed really important to me to speed
up the process of having those zero
prevalent studies so we can better
understand who was at risk and what the
right strategy ought to be